what's up everyone welcome to simulation
in now we're gonna be talking about
thoughts on Donald Trump hmm seems to be
a lot that's going on with Trump has
been a lot that's been going on actually
over the last couple of decades there's
been a lot going on with Trump but most
specifically I think what's interesting
is who he is because we don't quite know
exactly who he is but he sure has a
character and a personality that is so
much different than every single
president that we've ever seen before
now is this good in the long run is bad
in the long run who knows but what's
really interesting as we dive deeper
into what has been done is this idea of
nationalism many people take that
thought of nationalism and they
immediately take themselves back and
they're like whoa you know I'm very
global I have a very big
I don't want borders I don't want ego I
want to stall work together and across
the planet a lot of people do right but
a lot of people also want to take the
time getting to globalization getting to
the we are one mentality by making sure
that the United States actually thrives
as a democracy along the way because
something that could be true is that
maybe this short term nationalism is
actually good for the long term
democratic rule if the United States was
to open up its borders more more freely
if the United States was to take all the
trade deals that it possibly could even
if they weren't in the favor of the
United States if the United States
economy was to do things like provide a
lot of health care and a lot of
Education and a lot of these basic needs
that people need would people be more
creative would people be as innovative
would they go and hustle as much all
these different questions and how much
would that throttle away from our
military budget making sure that we can
keep that democracy there's all these
questions that go into this puzzle I
don't have
just talking about it as a stream of
consciousness and so I've learned from
people lots of people that are
geopolitical figures that are
geo-economic anima s-- people that are
studying the way that goods and
commodities are flowing across the
planet as well as the way that democracy
flows across the planet that maybe it's
true that that Trump being the bull in
the china shop and moving around all
this incumbent goop that's on the top of
the swamp was actually interestingly
enough good for the United States and so
maybe the short term nationalism maybe
maybe there's something to do with the
United States grouping itself together
saying hey borders are gonna be closed
off more tight for a bit we need to
figure our stuff out domestically we
need to maximize our research projects
into artificial intelligence into space
and into understanding these different
Sciences how they're applying to our
lives decentralization all these
interesting things we need to make
stricter deals across the borders with
your up stricter deals with Asia
stricter deals in general I'll be able
to do things like go and try and get
some peace with North Korea all this
different stuff that's going on more
peace in the Middle East try and figure
out how to do this and along the way
maybe that will help us become a the
world's leading democracy and continue
as the world's strongest economy I
always like to remind people that it was
actually not that long ago that women
didn't have the right to vote black
people were slaves Jews were being
annihilated in Europe that these all
these different genocides happening
across the planet still there are still
some that have just occurred a couple
dozen years ago so we're actually not
that civilized quite yet even though
over time we have gotten more civilized
it's so important to understand that the
United States as the leading economy and
democracy could be overthrown before you
know it by doing things like having
people become a little more complacent
to not be so concerned about the funding
the military all of a sudden another
military power comes in as like give us
your land give us your territory give us
your freedom we're gonna be
in control so this is all very important
things to take into account as we look
at the great picture of the earth
recently we learned that the the Roaring
Forties is a massive strip growing 40s
massive strip around the 40th parallel
on the on the it's a it's a line of
latitude fortieth line of latitude
parallel right here on the southern part
of the earth and the roaring 40s have
about 17 to 27 mile an hour winds and
the reason why I say this is because it
only takes 40 days for 0 40 days to sail
around the earth 40 days to sail around
the earth the earth is actually a fairly
small place and so in that regard
there's only one Rock there's only one
human experiment going on so in order to
retain it with as much democracy and
freedom as possible over time and make
sure you retain it especially as we move
into the artificial intelligence age and
the exponential technology age is really
important so maybe Donald is doing some
things right maybe it's important to be
a little bit more open-minded as a scout
Julia Galef was interestingly enough
teaching us about the importance of
being a scout instead of a warrior
Warriors are typically the ones that say
I'm right you're wrong I'm fighting from
my perspective which is a lot of the
right and left political gridlock the
Scout on the other hand is able to be an
independent observe what's going on the
right observe what's going on on the
left and remain neutral in a quantum is
observing these different perspectives
and saying things like hey let's have
this multivariate conversation this is
not about me being right if you say
something that's backed up by facts and
evidence I'm gonna say I was wrong and
I'm gonna take what you say and we're
gonna move on with it and that's a whole
different mentality to have and it's
important to be open-minded as we move
into there so just consider an ass food
for thought what's going on in this 2018
election cycle in 2020 election cycle
maybe there are some good things going
on for the economy and for the world in
the long run with what's going on with
Trump maybe there are some good things
just keep it as food for thought are
there also some bad things likely yes we
can also highlight and identify those as
well and so that's where the
multivariate conversation comes in
thanks for tuning in for this
quick session on thoughts on Donald
Trump will be coming back with you more
like this soon
go share what you learned two people
have them go share with two people let's
start spreading this message around have
the multivariate conversation about both
the good and the bad what's going on
with our geopolitics in geo-economics
much love everyone
you